Trascrizione: Carlo Schiatti
Revisore: Giovanni Brucoli
Ben trovati a tutti.
Da sempre sostenitrice della forza della mente
dalla quale poi parte tutta la nostra vita
e si basa tutta la nostra esistenza.
A mio modo "ricercatore":
ricercatore della qualità di vita.
A tal proposito vi leggerò un racconto
scritto
che spero poi vi permetterà di riflettere.
"Crescere significa mettersi alla prova".
Ogni giorno, svegliandosi, Siria,
così chiameremo la protagonista del nostro racconto,
avvertiva la stessa sensazione:
la luce che entrando dalle fessure
della finestra della sua camera
le permetteva, anche non guardando l'orologio, padrone del tempo,
di capire che era giunto il momento
di abbandonare faticosamente il suo letto.
E cominciare la sua giornata
segnava l'inizio di ogni giorno della sua vita,
il più importante.
Abitudinaria, come sempre
negli ultimi 25 anni della sua esistenza
nessuno poteva parlarle
prima che avesse bevuto il suo caffè,
e ancor prima che ne avesse respirato l'aroma.
E' proprio grazie all'oro nero
che tanti imprenditori si sono costruiti
il loro impero.
E sul quale vivono.
Insomma,Siria viveva ogni giorno come fosse il più importante
e chissà che non potesse diventarlo proprio in quel momento.
Così, tra i primi passi dentro casa,
le prime faccende da sbrigare,
la cura personale da rispettare,
la prole da svegliare, gli animali da sfamare,
e un minimo di diario di bordo, si comincia.
Qualcosa nell'aria, forse una presenza
l'aiuta ad avere ben chiaro che ci sono i piaceri ma anche i doveri.
E lei, a tutti gli effetti, ne ha molti da sbrigare
perché la quotidianità si riempie improvvisamente e continuamente di nuove sfide.
Problemi da risolvere differenti da quelli che si erano proposti il giorno precedente.
Forse nuovi traguardi da raggiungere.
Bando ai manuali,
ogni vita è unica.
Colorata da gioie, difficoltà, senso di solitudine;
ma anche persone sulle quali poter contare
anche solo per potersi liberare da ansie, timori,
piacevoli sensazioni di potenza,
per le donne legate esclusivamente ad uno stato ormonale;
alternate ad uno stato da ultima ruota del carro.
Quello che conta per oggi,
che è il giorno più importante,
è stabilire i propri bisogni
e implicitamente cercare un equilibrio con gli obiettivi
che potranno coincidere perfettamente
con quanto oggi la vita ci propone
o necessitare di limatura.
Ma ciò che conta è improntare un tenore
alla propria qualità di vita.
Le donne acrobate.
La donna, intrinsecamente e intimamente complicata,
legata alla pressione della società
che da lei vuol che sia femmina, mamma, lavoratore,
organizzatrice, intrattenitrice.
Ma su quale perno far ruotare realmente la sua esistenza?
No, non si tratta del lavoro e delle faccende di casa.
Non si tratta nemmeno della famiglia da accudire, che ha sempre mille richieste
e che lei accontenta.
Non si tratta nemmeno delle scadenze da rispettare,
quelle sono ovvie.
Si tratta, forse,della continua ricerca, della capacità
di mettere in bolla il suo stato d'animo.
Quell'armonia con se stessa, quel volersi bene,
quell'apprezzare i colori e i sapori della vita,
I batticuori, che alcune situazioni provocano in noi.
Quelle amarezze da inghiottire, quel sapore dolce o salato delle emozioni.
Gli occhi della gente che la incontra e che, senza pudore, le tolgono i vestiti
per cercare un punto dove affondare il loro colpo.
Ma anche avere sempre quella spalla pronta
e quelle braccia tese
ad abbracciare chi richiede supporto e comprensione.
Uno sguardo che parla, forse, a volte, fin troppo.
Siria è una giovine donna
estremamente pragmatica;
ha conquistato e ogni giorno lascia il segno in molte persone.
Spesso chi la conosce se ne innamora
perché con la sua empatia travolge chi la incontra.
Ha la fortuna di essere una bella donna,
sicuramente un facilitatore nei contatti sociali,
ma, delle volte, anche lama a doppio taglio.
Ogni giorno si ripete che è innamorata
che si nutre di emozioni, si nutre di vita.
Dalla vita vuole il succo,
della sua vita vuole esserne protagonista:
essere coinvolta in ogni azione che la riguarda.
Nessun spettatore in questo percorso
perché non ci sarà la possibilità di rivederlo.
Si è laureata ed ha conseguito l'iscrizione
che la lega all'albo degli psicologi.
Ma il suo paziente preferito
rimane sempre sé stessa.
Perché per capire gli altri ed essere in armonia con chi ci circonda
prima di tutto è necessario un lavoro di autoanalisi senza fine;
un continuo riallineamento
con sé stessi e con il mondo.
Perché questa è qualità della vita
e perché gli altri siamo noi.
E' una sorta di fonte eolica,
convinta che ogni persona sia portatrice di risorse
disposta a scambiare la sua energia con gli altri
proprio come una perfetta sinapsi.
E lei su questo argomento è preparata.
Crede nei cambiamenti ma non nei miracoli.
Lotta per cambiare i pregiudizi.
Lavora presso l'ufficio marketing di una nota multinazionale,
per la quale presta servizio da molti anni,
dove, come in ogni realtà lavorativa,
le realtà si ripetono, dove le dinamiche sono fatte di rivalità
di incomprensione, di competizione tra colleghi,
che spesso, pur essendo un gruppo di lavoro,
nella realtà troppo poco spesso riescono a lavorare in gruppo.
Punta sull'ascolto, sulla condivisione,
sulla fiducia e sul rispetto.
Si assume le sue responsabilità
anche davanti agli errori imbarazzanti,
e da lì cerca lo spunto per crescere.
E' esperta in grafologia
ma la sua vera passione rimane la musica.
Cantante e pianista, sostiene che nelle sue vene scorra il blues,
ma in realtà non è assolutamente in grado di suonarlo;
e spera che un giorno, improvvisamente,
lo scorrere sulla tastiera di un pianoforte delle sue dita
si possa trasformare in un'armonia pentatonica.
Si accompagna alla musica lasciandosi trasportare dalle sue vibrazioni.
In tutto questo,
nella sua esistenza,
nel ripetersi che ogni giorno,
che è questo il giorno più importante,
che gli altri siamo noi.
Siria non può mai tralasciare
che tutto questo lo fa
costretta su una sedia a rotelle.
E' paraplegica da ben oltre 20 anni.
Quel giorno,
anche quello il più importante
perché comunque è una pagina del diario della sua vita,
il suo tragico incidente motociclistico
nel quale il suo fidanzato di allora perse la vita
a soli 17 anni,
e lei, da poco quindicenne,
con il corpo completamente abraso dall'asfalto
a causa dell'attrito con il cemento
che per metri l'aveva consumata
violentando il suo giovanissimo corpo,
è stato comunque un giorno importante.
Lei da subito aveva avvertito di non poter più muovere le sue paffute gambe
e che qualcosa le stava sfuggendo di mano.
Anzi, ironia della sorte,
la situazione non era da prendere sottogamba.
Quell'incidente ha cambiato radicalmente
ed improvvisamente la sua vita.
Disabile, diversamente abile,
handicappato, portatore di handicap,
menomato, minorato, limitato, svantaggiato,
interdetto, invalido ...
A qualcuno viene in mente qualche altro aggettivo?
Non potrà mai dimenticare la diagnosi del medico:
Paraplegica
per lesione midollare completa.
Tantissimi i mesi trascorsi
tra rianimazione e reparto riabilitativo
in vari ospedali dell'hinterland milanese.
Tanta la confusione nella sua testa.
Nessuna certezza.
E in un momento come quello,
quello dell'adolescenza,
già popolato da strane idee
e voglia di possedere il mondo,
questa variazione sul tema della sua vita
non ci voleva proprio.
Insomma, le prospettive non erano delle migliori
e lei da subito, arrabbiata con il destino,
anzi, con chiunque le si avvicinasse,
perché convinta di dover pagare
una pena per la quale non aveva commesso reato.
Lei voleva solo vivere la sua vita.
Di tempo, da allora, ne è trascorso tanto.
Voglia di negare un profondo disagio?
L'espressione: "diversamente abile"
pone l'enfasi sulla differenza
tra il fare e il poter fare.
Si volta pagina.
Siria della diversità ne ha fatto un'opportunità
perché ha capito che per camminare
lungo la strada della vita
alle volte in salita,
anzi direi ... spesso in salita,
non sono indispensabili piedi che camminano
ma è sufficiente adeguare
il proprio approccio alla vita,
cercando di trarne sempre il meglio.
Ha deciso di sviluppare, attraverso quelle che erano le sue capacità residue,
abilità che forse non avrebbe mai nemmeno scoperto di avere.
o che comunque, adagiata ad una normale abilità,
non avrebbe potenziato o sfruttato.
Chiunque può tranquillamente affrontare una scalinata
ma molto spesso, all'arrivo, non si ricorda nemmeno
di averla percorsa.
Solo chi vive una difficoltà in prima persona
o da molto vicino,
nota determinate sfumature.
E in questo caso: barriere mentali e/o architettoniche.
Siria non si è mai impegnata in azioni sbalorditive
da record o da primato.
Ha deciso di vivere la sua vita
da diversamente abile
a qualunquemente disabile.
Non vuole stupire nessuno
ma guardarsi allo specchio
ed essere fiera di sé stessa.
La qualità della vita parte da dentro
di ognuno di noi.
Indipendentemente da quelle che sono le caratteristiche
fisiche, intellettive, creative e caratteriali.
E' un vestito che ognuno di noi deve cucire
addosso al proprio corpo.
L'elenco potrebbe proseguire
ma ciò che conta è essere in grado
di modellare la propria persona
all'ambiente circostante,
in modo da trarne il meglio
fino a spremerne l'ultima goccia.
Perché anche questo è il giorno più importante
e solo da questo presupposto
può partire un corretto approccio alla ricerca
di una buona qualità della vita.
Non ci sono paragoni con ausili
che possano tener testa ad un accomodamento
da parte della persona interessata.
Siria non potrà mai dimenticare
di essere disabile, diversamente abile,
handicappato, portatore di handicap,
menomato, minorato,
limitato, svantaggiato,
interdetto, invalido ...
non me ne vengono in mente altri al momento...
ma di certo ha imparato a rendere invisibile l'evidenza
continuando a vivere la sua vita.
Anche oggi
come ogni giorno della sua vita
si sente "qualunquemente dotata".
E quindi vuole continuare
a dare qualità alla sua esistenza.
Grazie.
(Applausi)